to actually be nominated I never thought
I would win first of all it's a a gory
horror movie the winner is Rick Baker
for an American Werewolf in
[Applause]
London this was a film that was made by
a director named John Landis and I I did
John lann's first film a film called
schlock John was telling me the story uh
that was going to be his next movie
doctor my memory is fine it's my sanity
I'm beginning to worry about told me the
whole story and his feeling was he said
we you know we both love the universal
classic horror films and all the jackn
hiy movies and things when a man changes
from a man into an animal John's feeling
was you know it seems like that would be
painful process and you wouldn't just
sit still in a corner of a chair like
lanen Jr when you transform so he said I
want you to figur out a way to do a
transformation where he can move around
and do things and I want it to be
painful Jesus
Christ what
God John always said the werewolf was
going to be a four-legged Hound from
hell he didn't want to bipad werewolf I
did kind of a comparative Anatomy study
and I have collection of stuff that I've
had over the years and I had a dog
skeleton and I have a human skeleton and
I was just looking at both you know and
what's different about the dog and the
human you know and you know the bones in
the hand you know the dog's paw you know
these bones are much longer so I thought
well yeah we could do that we could
stretch that out and then we can make a
hand where you see that stretch you know
and same thing with the feet and you
know the shape of the rib cage and the
body's longer I wasn't even think we
were going to make a whole head I
thought we'd make kind of three4 of a
head and then we decided we could make
the mechanisms
[Applause]
internal when American war came out
makeup effects was getting a lot of
publicity in a lot of the magazines I
got a lot of TV press and and I talked a
lot about makeup and and how there
wasn't a category and stuff like that
yes I do look most unpleasant there were
films like the Elephant Man and then
just the history of films Wizard of Oz
and all these films that the makeup is
so important to it you know why isn't
there a category and the academy finally
came around and decided fortunately for
me that year that it's time for it to be
an official category first of all I'd
like to thank the academy for creating
this new C and I'm very proud to be the
first
winner I could not believe that that
this that this happened to me you know
this kid that grew up in cavina you know
making monsters in his
[Applause]
[Music]
bedroom